what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch brooklyn nine nine today i wanna
give you guys a clue this is john's
neutral face before we film then when i
go what's up or something he goes
that's right man i'm activated for
camera your voice just brings the joy
out of me
the recording just the something washes
over me and i can see the screen every
time
all right i'm going to start a really
slow hit the freaking like button
subscribe and click that notification
bell also check us out on patreon and
cover full-length watch logs for
brooklyn nine-nine over there to cover a
bunch of shows as well
same tier for reaction highlights and
watch alongs included homeboys over for
prep prep prepper for editing on these
highlights let's do it
[Music]
our drug task force was a success and
today i get to watch my nemesis madeline
wunsch drape a medal around my neck
she's back she's about to choke you with
that model i have the perfect line lunch
time is over
it's a play on lunchtime yeah you know
what would really show her is if you
said nothing at all oh interesting
interesting
let madeleine know she's not even worth
my staying up all night crafting zingers
lunchtime took you all night trust me
did you say that before yeah i feel like
it
definitely a lunch joke for meritorious
service the nypd
bestows detectives rosa diaz jake
peralta and captain
raymond holt
wonderful delivery go ahead and gloat
you toad thank you for this honor
deputy chief
oh hmm
lunch time is over
[Music]
both ways no regrets
[Laughter]
that's the first time he came across
obviously gay yeah
gotta gotta you know
expand that character palette out
or if i didn't know he was gay would i
have thought that was obviously gay
probably not that's the question
we have intel on a drop house we need a
couple of teams to do long-term
stakeouts i'm out four hours is the most
i've ever spent alone with any human it
was the worst experience of my life what
about that time we drove out to boston
together that was about four hours ah
oh i see what just happened
it's an eight-day op so two teams will
do four days each boyle and i are in
who wants to relieve them if extraction
is a risk the two of us can do the full
eight days a hanukkah miracle
we never fight it won't be a stakeout
it'll be a steak cation
i don't want to let you go till we catch
this guy we already have a theme song
that concludes this meeting it's like
when we decided to live together that's
right oh well great live right down the
hall
i'm making my twins a picture book for
their birthday it's called junebug and
cricket adventure girls
whoa this one looks just like you gina
and this one's definitely you look how
masculine the clothes are
pants suit of armor the drawings look
like you two they should make those the
whole squad's in here tiny squirrel is
charles
[Laughter]
and the hippo with heads on both ends
that's hitchcock and scully yes
this is a real small room if you start
getting on each other's nerves go to
separate corners we call it a loan zones
all due respect sarge but we don't need
alone zones no we do not
let me ask you a question how do we feel
about scone zones i feel great about it
i made the perfect ringtone listen
stake me out tonight i don't want to let
you go till we catch the guy
all right we got banach that is on so
many people's phones
everyone this is my nephew marcus
yo i came to get the keys from my uncle
ray let everybody get back to work
eminem hates you
holy moses all right carrie why what for
you that's basically walking up to him
and jamming your tongue down his throat
but let me just add one little thing off
topic
rosa wants to bone your neck
[Laughter]
wow that sleep apnea mask is something
else huh oh i gotta say ever since i got
her her she touches my lips jake she's a
her
hey this is a kind of weird request but
would you maybe mind chewing your north
flusters with your mouth closed i can't
and i'm excited to tell you why
uh open mouth oxygenate the food so it's
kind of like wine tasting yeah and i
hear you buddy
i don't complain about how gross your
meal is what's gross about pancakes with
butter and maple syrup you've completely
abandoned the pancake part now you're
just eating butter with syrup on it yeah
i cut out the carbs this is me being
healthy
oh yeah
wait that's alone zones
we don't need loans oh no
no keep that shoe hole open
[ __ ] hey listen about our
alone zone close call oh that that's not
a big deal we're not gonna start
fighting we never fight yeah totally
yeah that's what i was thinking
but just to be safe we could write down
some of each other's annoying behaviors
that we want to be off limits you know
the no-no list oh i love it
oh no
so here's what i've got for you no
eating with your mouth open we knew that
no rastaman voice
no ballroom dancing no bird calls and no
male kegels can i do my kegels secretly
watch this you'll never know i'm doing
them
no talking about die hard
okay oh no or die hard two or die hard
three what
come on so you just want me to talk
about the fourth one there's a fourth
one charles
no eating mayonnaise straight from the
jar no using my toothbrush and that's it
jake no use of my toothbrush
you remember my nephew marcus the 31
year old the 31 year old
this is defining trait
but if marcus wants my number
he can ask me for it
what spots whoa
but who will tell him
[Laughter]
[Music]
um yeah you took the last danish oh
sorry did you read terry's book about us
no he said not to read it
okay fine i read it my character cricket
is such a pushover she just lets all the
forest folk take her magic moose wishes
well junebug is a stone cold [ __ ]
is that how people see us well you did
just steal that danish out of my hand
and start eating it and i let you
and apologized classic cricket move hey
you can scooch your ass back in line
my coffee needs are just as important as
yours
maybe i should go check on little amy
and give her the greatest gift of all
a hug
i mean we've made it impossible to annoy
each other
we're gonna make out with the stakeout
hmm
hey bud is rhyming on your no-no list
no
cool cool seems pretty close to reciting
poetry yeah
yeah but it's different yeah oh
i'm just gonna add it
oh so uh so we can add things now yeah
why not right i mean we got the time and
we got the ink everything but the cajon
sang what did i just say
[Music]
no yoga that's impressive no letting
it
mellow no
sister
sharpie no life hacks no multi-level
marketing schemes
no calling legitimate business idea
scheme
[Music]
ceremony no cabbage patch no no guys the
the stakeout old lady style towels
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god no nose hair trimming we're here
for eight days jake i don't care it's on
the list well i hope you like nostril
bush
astral bush all right no more talking no
more talking at all three two one no
talking zip it
hey captain how's the operation going
people thought you'd be at each other's
throats by now
do you need a relief team
no sassy not us
what is that
need a relief team everything's going
great right boyle right so great good
see you in a couple of days okay that
sounds good bye i love you what
we all love captain holt hold the door
sorry sarge maybe if you did more cardio
and less weights you've moved back no no
no
see in the elevator
no
what is going on with you two
going on with you love love
you wanna know what's going on we read
your book i'm not a pushover and i'm not
a stone-cold [ __ ] i'm a natural
beautiful present
junebug is a meanie to the plotty pups
but she's a sweetheart to the sacrifice
and cricket is a pushover when it comes
to magic moose wishes but she's very
brave in the dolphin wars
[Laughter]
you hadn't stopped the elevator you
could have walked off after your great
speech now we all got to sit in it
[Laughter]
you're up early
okay
[Music]
hey
rosa marcus kevin uncle ray marcus and
cheddar cheddar is also here
my being here is weird this was a bad
idea we shouldn't see each other again
well detective rosa diaz is left
[Laughter]
she's gonna explode the only reason we
don't fight is because i never say
anything when you annoy me which is
constantly baby i just let it roll off
baby back baby stop
and if you don't like this stuff then we
shouldn't be friends great because guess
what we're not friends
that's fine with me baby
oh
god what have you done
cover blown
uh oh
god
yeah well the operation is blown
take me out tonight
we told you eight days was too long for
a stakeout with all due respect sir it
wasn't the amount of time it's who i was
stuck there with i could easily have
done it with scully really
you need to find bisco you can start by
doing door duty see if anyone knows
where he is i'm speaking to you as a
friend not a captain and as your friend
i have this brazier you left behind in
marcus's room
[Music]
also
i just wanted you to know um i i think
marcus is great and uh and you're great
and i hope the fact that you and i work
together won't prevent you from dating
if that's
what you want to do
i might
but i don't want to talk to you about it
perfect because i'm not comfortable
knowing about it then let's never talk
about it let's never talk about anything
done
let's just get this over with
you guys are going to do great
yes
[Music]
oh no stunt double oh golly
alexi bisco
you're under arrest
thanks for having my back you don't have
to thank me i've always got your back
look this whole thing has been so stupid
right are we friends again no
oh
best friends we're brothers oh god it's
terrifying don't pause like that
my brother had sex with my wife and then
he ran to the florida key just be
arrested man we're trying to have a
moment here
[Laughter]
quality you are strictly a co-worker
oh i can't make that you
are just a means to an end
i think everyone can pick up on that
yeah it's very clear yeah when the
agency put us together they knew
this was going to be difficult
let's have dos cavazos marry her
let's do that let's put this group of
the people for the normies these white
guys at blind waves seem like they'd be
good friends yeah yeah let's put them
together what do we got left over yeah
we got these two uh oddballs one
ethnically ambiguous one looks like he
belonged the blind wave crew
we have an extra blind wave what do we
do with it i don't know there's too many
blind waves at that moment let's put him
up with this guy
yeah man thanks stephen you're youtube
you're welcome
wow
the relevancy of today's episode yeah
all of us having to deal with a
quarantine situation
now them forced into a quarantine-like
situation countdown of eight days watch
as they deteriorate perfect setup why
haven't we gotten more movies that deal
with such a plot
oh yeah you could do just like an hour
and a half long no no you could do an
anthology show
if every different stakeout or
quarantine scenario there's one building
where everyone is quarantined together
for different reasons and they all come
together for a big team up to take down
the virus yes
yeah nice work yeah i'm gonna put that
on the list any
combining the words
cheekily
yeah that would definitely go and go on
the list i think if anyone can relate to
this episode it's greg and josh
yeah we are we are charles and uh
peralta plenty of times we're on like
like we just need some space
to take a break we're just in this room
together see some other people so often
maybe i spend some time alone
i just need something
trust me you guys have no idea you're
like
living together it was even worse yeah
yeah there's a whole bunch of
a bunch of stories we could identify
with space is good space is healthy
spaces very necessary space is a
makes the heart grow fonder it does
start like that though always starts
with something so minor oh yes little
the little annoyances or you're like
and now also there's like an avalanche
of other peeves
that one peeve yeah we uh it's funny we
didn't fight for like years yeah until
we were like
same attitude dude it's gonna be like
boot camp come on man finally after all
these years partner up with me let's go
full time let's go come on man come on
let's live together you got to learn the
ropes come on yeah
oh boy that was a journey i mean you
know we feel like we would have periodic
fights when we were growing up it's like
you know every now and again oh nowhere
near as yeah but no
there was like there was like years
without it yeah suddenly it was like oh
it's back
yeah so
so this brought up a lot of traumatic
memories no but we are we are like
brothers yeah we are the type that like
no matter how big big we've got
really big fights yeah i don't know how
big of a fight we get into we we
we're not even at that point where we
can we can dissolve it with a joke
sometimes yeah later on yeah like
we did it all right
[Music]
keep on growing and trucking yeah so i
like seeing that captured here in this
22-minute chunk yeah because that is
very relatable
see it might sound like all you guys did
was talk about yourselves what we did
was make it the most personal brooklyn
nine-nine review you could have ever
held on yeah that's something lucky for
you guys who stuck around this long yeah
those pearls of humanity
and uh we had nick cannon here not do
anything that was uh he's probably gonna
come back that's the thing yeah i'll
come back and be something it made me
want to go back and re-watch the episode
because it felt like that whole plot
line like almost didn't i couldn't tell
if it was intentional or if it really
was like the slightest it felt like it
was really happening like in the deep
background of the episode because even
with rosa like the first time nick
cannon even shows up at the office like
there's that whole thing about like she
she just gives him a look when gina
points her out yeah yeah yeah so like i
i wonder if this was something they
attempted to do in a more sort of like
wry subtle way but but in the immediacy
of the episode is like oh that's right
nick cannon showed up earlier yeah i
completely forgot until the end he's a
pretty big guest star yeah didn't
wait a minute
didn't nick cannon host america's got
talent at one point or some other show
and then was it then terry crews took
over
oh hey is that what it is i don't watch
those shows i don't remember which one
it was but you might be right i mean
they both definitely hosted the that
posted nbc shows yeah yeah yeah
dad terry crews was like hey i got you
you got to come and get it yeah
it was fun watching holt be more
uncomfortable it's like this was holt
was like primarily human for most of
this yeah
barely he but i mean like from the
beginning he just really was like he
smiled a lot more he was excited he
broke he broke against what he normally
does he's on stage and really behaved
more like peralta
yeah yeah when getting watch oh my god
lunch time's over i thought he said that
in another episode he definitely yeah
because there's a discussion i think
even between him and peralta or him and
somebody about the the onech pun yeah so
i if it wasn't this specific phrase he's
definitely made lunch puns that are
lunch
yeah yeah
but then watching him get uncomfortable
with rosa and having to deal with that
level of work environments that's what i
mean like everything was more about less
bits about him being stoic cold captain
and more about
uh just him
being an awkward captain
in this position that almost felt like
the theme of this episode is it's like
the against character episode because
then you have that with amy and uh and
uh gina as well and i thought that was
pretty amusing just watching them get so
riled up over this this story that
terry's making and i wonder if he drew
those because he's an artist
so maybe you know that would be fun a
fun easter egg all right terry crews
draw draw the reason we're not gonna pay
you anything
uh draw these things that are gonna be
featured on national television
yeah hopefully we're not gonna hire
someone to do this while you're resting
we don't pay you to just act no i pay
you to be an artist sometimes you eat
yogurt and make art
uh yeah i thought that was really fun i
actually thought gina was one of her
funniest episodes i i love the way she
plays the opposite like you know giving
caring gina because it's exactly the
same as the other one to the point where
it's like she'll say a nice thing and it
still feels like some kind of cast
equipment yeah which i think was was
really i've got a big kick out of that
yeah you know it's like it's it's almost
effortless in the moment but the
attitude exactly feels the same
good show man absolutely always good
good good
i've been watching the movie that's my
boy periodically in little chunks
in little 22 minutes 15 to 30 20 minute
trunks
so it's fun watching adam sound learn
that oh yeah maybe he'll show up not
adam sandler [ __ ] i mean isn't that
but uh andy sandberg watch andy sandberg
and adam sandlerberg
yeah they play father and son yeah have
you seen it no i keep meaning to watch
it because i remember wow remember when
you told me about it you called me up
and you were like i just saw this movie
called that's my boy
and it was surprisingly really funny i
don't think a lot of people are gonna
like it
but andy sandberg is really good at it
and and and uh what did you tell me you
told me adam sandler is actually
committed
yeah actually played the character so
it's always stuck out of my mind it's a
r-rated
adam sandler comedy that's not on
netflix it was meant for the people
to be seen big and i think it's better
than people it's definitely would not
if it came out today
oh no there would be problems maybe
it would be canceled i remember like
part of the premise
because isn't andy sandberg like the
product of him hooking up with his
teachers as like yeah yeah
yeah but everyone when he does it
everyone's like
yes yes that is a textbook i know right
you want to watch you're my boy
i'm a boy
that's my boy that's a boy
in the remake
my boy
a badass
oh all right guys hey we should do a pic
jason dolan
jason my man if there's someone that i
could be holed up with for a while for a
few days
it'd be you man you would talk my ear
off
you just would not shut up you'd be full
of thoughts talking movies anytime i
bring up a subject you just
let me tell you my new movie idea let me
tell you why i don't agree with this
popular opinion about cinema do you have
letterboxes yeah
does not stop you're one person who i
know would just keep me i'd be asleep
and you'd still be talking to me
it's like a white noise machine yeah
i i could zone you out and you wouldn't
even notice and that's the perfect kind
of individual you got to be holed up
with who can keep themselves immunized
by talking and then you can check in
periodically and catch their rhythm yeah
yeah i just think you'd be the perfect
gentleman for such an occasion oh you
already look like you're quarantined all
the time yeah you have a stakeout vibe
yeah you got the beanie and the hair and
the scraggles yeah you look like like a
little on kemp these days and then the
right way that doesn't you're not you
you haven't teetered to homeless they
still look like you year but you have
them harmingly dishonest
this was a choice i'm just saying like
if there's someone who matches the being
holed up in a crappy apartment vibe it's
you
it's the biggest compliment i could give
you
and tell you merry christmas jason i
hope you've liked your shout out for the
end of 2021
[Music]